known here simply as the man on the
horse the statue of prince albert has
watched over wolverhampton for more than
150 years
through the booming industrial era to
this
among the empty buildings the city's
once famous grand department store now
home only to those with nowhere else to
go
ambitious plans to transform derelict
buildings are already underway over a
thousand new homes being built at this
former brewery
now ministers say millions more will be
spent on the city
the government says its leveling up
funding will breathe fresh life into
disadvantaged communities providing
housing leisure and business in
sustainable walkable beautiful new
neighborhoods but is that what people
here really want
i'm cynical because anytime they say
that they're going to give money to
somewhere it's got to come from
somewhere first doesn't it we need some
more investment in within the town
centre as well there are shops that
close down there's not a lot of like
leisure activities to do i guess because
if people want to have fun they just go
to birmingham wolverhampton and
sheffield are the first of 20 areas to
be selected to be prioritized for a
share of 1.5 billion pounds but the
money isn't new it's part of 1.8 billion
pounds for regeneration promised at the
last budget
labor say it's like handing a few areas
of fibre
if you want king's cross style
regeneration you've got to put money
back into people's pockets so that they
can spend you've got to get those good
jobs back in king's cross cost three
billion to redevelop the government's
stake alone was worse three times what
they're giving to the entire rest of the
country with this money that's been
recycled from the budget some see the
timing of the announcement as an attempt
by a wounded prime minister to regain
support in parts of the midlands and
north the public are pretty wise they
know that these kinds of announcements
are are political uh as well as policy
um they know that places like sheffield
and wolverhampton need money there's no
question the city centre in sheffield uh
needs a lot of investment it's never
recovered from the de-industrialization
the loss of the steel industry but many
will welcome any funding for places that
have often felt forgotten becky johnson
sky news wolverhampton